yeah oh and welcome to this rapid game
on DHS SOA lesyk
let's take is no opponent what am i
playing okay that's go c5 play Sicilian
mixing it up
so what to do here can try to go for I
had some good success with them Roxy
point I don't know if I get it though
let's try so I'm not getting the Roxy
rather normal-ish dragon setup you
should see for now there are a couple of
things I can play I think in castles we
should be three knows castles so this is
probably not so critical because of
90-84 is you
yeah 94 I think I can play this move
taken before now for the g5 fork and
it's potentially very simplifying though
you
yeah d6 is also cool so I want to have a
little bit more tension on the board
maybe 90s for theoretically more
reliable move let's aim but in general
the dragon structure is believed to be
very okay with the white castling short
more critical are those some sharp lines
it's a for now so it looks a little
abused I don't have a don't have a
technical way of handling this Luke CH
that looks like a standard move
Jim I'm not sure how this is played to
be honest there is some pressure on its
own yet drinking and bishops e6 looks
like the most normal choice just wonder
if this is so really correct but I think
it's okay so Bishop d6 I don't think he
fired is dangerous and they have 97 next
a7 is hanging but before is also hanging
some that that's not going to be going
to be an issue
you
it's a very normal play to trade on
deform and I want to trade one or two
pairs of minor pieces because of my
space disadvantage so he probably wants
to push me five in some way
v gjxc 5 at 65 no so here move that
looking interesting here is to play me 5
immediately pawn takes knight disability
it looks wrong so on 97 is the most but
I'm going to do that so we traits
it's not so easy for white in this
position to find a constructive plan
it's also in the f5 gives me the e5
square and e5 is opening up my Bishop 1
c6 and weakens the pawn structure it's
of course also not entirely trivial for
me to do something but I think I'm
starting with this check and putting the
Queen on to c5 this is making b5 more
difficult and activates the queen b5 now
is the possibility Knight to d5 is a
move that is to be reckoned with
I don't know probably just kooky ain't
the creamer was a bit surprising
I mean Queen d4 the move that I'm I
would be quite happy about the Queen
trade is useful for black hen
is it normally is in the Sicilian in the
Sicilian structure you usually want to
trade if there are weaknesses for white
a little bit a little bit clearer
weaknesses efore is a slightly weaker SH
pawn and c2 is on a verb and file the
black pawn structure is more difficult
to to attack it's very compact mmm yeah
Quigley voice is clearly his intention I
just wonder what I should play so that
is so that he's actually encouraged to
play it hmm I don't quite know maybe
behind I'm not quite certain if I want
to do this but this is at least
threatening before and Bishop to b5
yeah before we should be five wins an
exchange let's that's a threat
the be files also remove that fit into
this position on general terms before or
if I have a forum are useful ideas I'm
sure what is doing a queen deform yeah
so I'm I don't mind that of course
that's a useful trade so to apply a five
in this position or not I think I do
yeah Avery looks quite normal here
maybe we should be five then I can
probably take yeah III is more is the
most term standard looking looking
choice yeah so a 95 is probably a temple
gain yes he wants to keep the bishop
you should a to who came each five I can
always take this is not an issue at all
maybe we'll be eight and look FCA
next so that I have both walks on the
Queen side I'm intending also 95 and
then before or before immediately maybe
so it seems that if five is on this
agenda okay do I go before here or not
before takes takes night a to s is
possible however yes so maybe I'll jump
into c5 and leave the D file so that
before hive is not a threat anymore he
had this a5 idea we can light back on
this heaven there was a lot of pressure
on that piece and what I want to do is
likely before undermined the color of
the e-force free-form so let's see what
he does if he goes in five I think I can
just take it this should be a should be
okay go yet understand if he goes in
five and I go d KX f takes it's a bigger
phone running okay so this was one of
the possible moves the move before now
is very interesting before Bishop c6 b
takes its got before then continued
kinkle 96 okay that's not a problem
yeah but then then before it's just good
at least oh good structure for me so the
line I was calculated was okay take on
two sixty one two three before a Bab
ninety-six okay he I'll take with the
pawn of course otherwise that wouldn't
make any sense
Wow what is he doing him that's very
quickly played and it looks like
completely lost almost and threatening
ninety-six Sierra winning at four and if
I win this pawn white pawn structure is
completely ruined
so 96 or let's not let's not rush things
let's not rush things
good night a six
the only other movement it doesn't make
any sense so okay ninety-six it's
probably playing hooky three then I take
f4 with a tempo and then the only thing
that is somewhat irritating is that he
might and keep the Alcorn okay so I just
take f15 doesn't work
you
is got to be five on the cost I mean
it's not again it's not the end of the
world but so where to put it so look
here how do I play this I would like to
keep my pawn there of course look FC
eight rooks III rook takes b5 this would
be cute but it is not forced
you
[Music]
who say anything else 92 looks very
ridiculous we will take this next again
it's not such a big issue that he takes
it but if I can keep it this look
everyone in g5 makes some sense okay I
put a chair
now look see three will be five is very
bad for white so we cannot take this hmm
I wonder what he will do maybe just g3
or something no we're h3 is hanging
sorry that doesn't make any sense
what am i overlooking I'm just taking
this here now that's a pin I mean
without the b-pawn why it's position
should be completely losing what am I
missing here don't get
everyone and so I didn't miss anything
he just goes into this losing ending
it's a pawn down and it's a very bad
structure for white will most likely win
material cge pawn one of those three I
will win I don't think he can defend
them all this one okay
sorry this is possible
okie-dokie King up to e5 it's the most
normal way of doing it let's do it
look f1 king e5 yeah
okay so all the way to e5
yeah maybe I'm just settling to take on
D 393 pancakes King before and I'm
snatching the pawn and I take takes king
now it probably wins I also have the
chick in general I don't like to take
them
I probably just winds down takes pawn
takes King default a one chick named
interest wins
I mean the light is obviously a lot
stronger than the bishop but if you can
trade it down to this kind of ending it
doesn't matter all that much yeah so um
let's have a look there I think you
played not far too quickly in the in the
critical phase of the game maybe I
missed some stuff as well I don't know
well see what what happens here with the
analysis the soul and we have a
completely normal position here I think
night 64 is probably the most principled
move I didn't do this because I felt
that I may betray too much I mean to try
to win you know I saw this line and I
kind of thought that ok maybe I'm okay
but I'm trading the whole border I
wouldn't be to me win ce6 and maybe this
is ok but it's not I'm not very exciting
so I played these things which cannot be
bad played age 348 or super normal so I
took it we should see six it's
interesting the engine here is
advocating f5 it was not that a
particularly high depth sell
and now Queenie tours play that also
didn't feel like a bad move 97 and the
trade thank you one yeah I felt it's a
good idea to put the Queen on to c5 so I
went went with this not not the only
only thing
another question the chat with it it was
question about 94 and I just said that I
didn't want to try too much and only
three maybe is a bit lame of d5 now you
see the engine is also favoring like
already it's um it makes it easy for for
whites for for black to play would be
aids also like by the column let's see 5
because White has the c5 ideas over I
went here and the move before it's not
liked by the engine yeah it's clear that
this is a move of course which I thought
about before would be nice but it seems
fair
it isn't all that great yeah I mean one
line and that was not played yeah I was
thinking maybe he just recaptured a lot
of prospects the engines always the
engine not liking this hybrid what's
wrong with this in particular the engine
wants to do this
and then before I saw that but isn't
that good I thought this is code for
black this is almost this again it's
just the game well mainly it isn't that
great it's possible that I had something
that is a more it's more convincing but
I like this position and the domain and
the main problem this group takes you
three this is just basically losing I
believe with the engine here neighbors
as mistake but it's probably a it's a
real blunder after we five I'm getting
rid of the only worrisome pawn in the
board the phone is gone now and yeah I
got the much better structure yeah many
many things ring probably and can also
just keep everything on the board that
bus is probably the most straightforward
to to make progress into position
yeah okay I hope you guys enjoyed it
thanks for watching